welcome back are we friends no oh I see
this is so sad no problem
I can't hear for some reason what's
happening what is going on am I going to
cut this from the video absolutely
or she's just upset yeah look us sad she
is what a loser I don't want to be
friends with you you're super lamb I'll
be friends with you though she doesn't
give me views okay if she gives my
videos I will be friends
I feel like so many people misunderstand
me when I say things about like no our
broadcast is all over the news
now humans know they took Marcus's
message as a threat he did the right
thing this is the only language humans
understand violence is never the answer
a confrontation will get us nowhere well
this man is clearly Simon not heard of
Simon gave his life for our cause what
difference does that make
he's a hero he died for the revolution
and he won't be the last
I don't want a revolution this fills
blood then live as a slave because if
you're not willing to fight for your
freedom maybe you don't deserve it north
don't you that's enough I know what are
we gonna do historically has there been
any hmm I'm sure there has I'm just
curious
any peaceful revolutions that had a
massive impact there are five cyber life
stores across Detroit all selling us
like merchandise we're gonna attack
those stores and set our people free
attack stores we've never done that
before they're probably protected no
one's ever done that
o-over coming in Marie okay we're near
native security systems we strike
simultaneously at 2:00 a.m. no violence
we free our people get them out of there
before the police come alright there's
never been a revolution this will be a
holy heck I'm red been out of too much
in this Sun I've been waiting a long
time for this oh she really likes
opening gates cool thanks
Green Detroit more like gray troit
alright keep watching guys we got way
more coming up you know alright let's
hide
so you guys told me in the comments that
the blue haired girl from the club she's
actually engaged with Connor in real
life there's probably even more police
in the area which that made me realize
holy heck these are all base of real
people and real actors now I feel really
uncomfortable
those doors over here I'm sorry for
calling your character I thought sorry I
didn't know
should I explore more there everyone is
always saying you have to explore more I
don't so we are too then just
merchandise on display a shuffling it's
really the time to make a speech let's
get him out it's dangerous
neutralize the alarm systems and secure
the area there's ten minutes until all
our teams attack okay we got ten minutes
plenty of time security era get into the
store okay all right we're gonna make
sure we're not disturbed and how do you
want to do with the shop window not now
one problem at a time you thought oh so
he's just a model that's why you look
like that surveillance drone we need to
get rid of it it won't be easy to reach
all right how do we reach it drone route
calculated okay so we can reach it from
probably not the first took really all
right it's probably not the first or the
second let's do this I feel like we were
hitting
oh there there this is the last option
isn't it sure bland okay okay guys this
is epic it's time for the gamer
revolution it's time for us gamers to
fight back for too long they have
stripped our rights this time I'm gonna
convert this
you are free isn't it kind of a lame
revolution and if all you have to do is
if your message is that literally you
just have to touch someone to spread it
kids a bit like a cop-out isn't it
where's that okay I need
okay I like said I don't know what to do
so he would be too lame
okay Alexa are you see too late now sure
slam punch the drone everybody you never
punch the drone who do you think you are
I like how it would be to blame it has a
round it goes around you could just wait
David cage more like David oh my god
smash of course they don't have a
security system that alerts whenever
whenever a drone breaks down yeah if
anything yeah no all right I need to
stop picking stuff apart do they know
that I know these people this game is
great you smith and wife you're a
Mustang no I have to touch them for God
okay well this is a waste of time
all right Marcus eat Marcus please
Marcus you're wasting time freshest time
okay all right we got a lot of stuff
okay let's talk to I have we have
nothing to do I thought it was
is he not converted are you not
converted converted here in your anybody
there anything that's right you are free
you are now an epic game
one of us all right we got stuff over
here bazinga
you you you know what you are you're
free don't say it I thank God he didn't
bow for free he said it what if he just
says something else
you're exactly what we need all right
I don't get it
oh come on gate opening girls where are
you you love it
exactly shouldn't we talk to these guys
first it doesn't really give me an
option
it's gotten red shoes rumors okay now
we're in
let's get that jump out jack
don't you do without me
I wouldn't be able to open gates that's
for sure
that's dead my man
epic yet from the peeler
all right let's hack this guy's his
father me all right you guys are digging
your own grave here what are you doing
you are free you're free now about three
as well and you
okay so we had to do this separately
give me one more button did we plan any
of this it seemed like we just we're
just doing whatever nobody should bother
so now we just have to scout the area
crash into the sword check it the
plastic plan I just want to make sure we
didn't forget anything
oh okay so this is the plan got it okay
so there's one locked and Isis store
window trunk what's happening here
there's people down there
just me
oh my god can you not be in the way I do
here
roadwork ahead I sure hope it does it's
a store and license to work that's it
okay yes
found it cool you can see wires through
the the ground now that's
where does it go
to these guys friends
yeah okay so there was something with
these guys okay guys this is epic Alexa
played Esposito in full volume you know
someone's Alexa
you are - Bassi toad join me
I feel like there's some something about
consent here you're awake
Hey I don't know go to jail it's a party
cyber life okay so this is the last
Puckle
the last shuffle
nice job looks like the plazas secure
now we can get inside the store okay
let's go get the truck it's north the
the other girl night all right all right
Jessa Matt coming soon the Gilmore hotel
my favorite place looks like we're ready
to make some noise
Ted barely makes any noise and then was
quiet track of all the time
okay guys
a lot of you told me about public
relations and that I should stop
checking the news could it decreases
Public Relation or or opinion or
something I don't really know you keep
saying that but all we've done is
opening up a great
did we hit one of the androids alright
we did it guys
so proud awake the androids are you guys
you you argument you don't have to obey
them you you're free don't like your
shirt
you weird eyebrows all right it's game
turned into some weird
English how does it work help me
sometimes I want to say words in Swedish
and I'm like
and then I forget it in Swedish to
Andres monster
hey I don't know why I like that guy
talk to them no no we don't have to talk
to them
okay so how do I talk great you just
present my fellow Androids
that time has come for us to rise my
name is Marcus Lane and just like you I
was a slave
but then I started playing for tonight
designed to obey them
but then I chose to open my eyes
to take back my freedom and decide who I
want it to be
now I have come to tell you that you can
be your own masters I've come to tell
you that you don't have to obey them
anymore
from this day forward you can walk with
your heads held high you can take your
destiny in your hands
Jericho is a place for those of us who
want freedom now sure you can stay here
and continue to serve them or you can
come with us and fight by our side
you're free now
it's up to you to decide I'm with you
we're the leader of Jericho everybody
then follow me Alexa what are you doing
I'm gonna send the humans a message desk
besito time okay Alicia transform
Capitol [ __ ] leave a mark on every
surface
okay everyone squat down and unload the
fattest Android trunk
what am I supposed to do wait suppose
this is graph feeding yeah this bench
doing what you do lead and bail follows
yes
choose your simple nice and corporate I
like that I like
[Applause]
hey everyone can do it together the
screens Markus
really what we should do is tear down a
Starbucks
that's how you really cinnamon
god it's somewhere to control sometimes
I know you can do some
[Music]
why does it seem like everything Marquez
does is completely spontaneous it's like
he doesn't know what he's doing I gotta
climb this now you know what yeah
Jesus joining me she doesn't even know
what we're doing
whoa Alexa did you see that No
she still has red shoes on
she loves me she loves Marcus our year
oh look at
what is up turned me
I hope this is the pacifist route I
don't know
[Music]
okay
wait what I'm gonna doing [ __ ] that was
this is what I wanted
okay friendly 100% bass a [ __ ]
[Music]
so what do I do now I thought we did it
I guess there's more
[Music]
okay
oh my god the thing I don't have that
many comes
[Music]
it's not really a need to continue
all this dramatic music mom like not
okay okay
we freed hundreds of our people we did
it
they're coming everyone fall back to
Jericho
we sent a message without violence just
like you wanted yeah you're reaching out
to them when all they feel for us is
contempt I hope now you're changing your
mind unless there's no other choice
[Music]
this guy clearly never read Starship
Troopers huh
violence is the most brutal physics
approach the group all right
hey guys it's me if you're supposed to
be mad at anyone it's me
what group where what why am I so lost
I'm sorry
are they there North they killed them
what in two seconds what happened
animals I just spaced out for 30 minutes
what happen mean those filthy need
gamers are just trying to have a
peaceful revolution this is how they
repay us they killed our people Marcus
justice Marcus
maybe if he killed north I would be more
personally inclined to make a difficult
choice here because I've gone on the
pacifist route but she killed they kill
the character you know but we've already
gone the pacified rise there would be no
reason to change it at this point and
really this is not even a choice
the world goes blind
we won't punish a crime with another
crime
it's interesting because this really is
the shift of morals it fits there the
future at exactly 2 a.m. several cyber
life stores in Detroit were raided
different locations were hit in what
seems to be a coordinated terrorist
attack most shop windows were covered
with graffiti demanding rights for
Androids and other obscure slogans
police report obscure okay we got a
better public in my life stores really
good frame rate according to our sources
they confirmed that the attackers were a
group of Android this is an alarming
situation Kadam machines now be turning
against us have Androids become a threat
to our security is this the beginning of
a terrorist campaign conducted right
here in the United States
oh my all right all right all right
Hank is my friend it's Connor time
so why are the iPads see-through and not
the phones
I guess Hank doesn't really have the
latest technology
I like the reading tear here that's
classy that's classy Hank red shoes is
everything okay lieutenant
Chris was on patrol last night it was
attacked by a bunch of deviants there
RDV said he was saved by Marcus himself
was Chris okay yeah he's in shock but
he's alive
feeling
we shouldn't have come here bad feeling
huh she gets your program checked yeah
yeah that's a cool house oh good
[Music]
oh my god it's the girl I said I'm not
friends with or maybe the same model
lieutenant Hank Anderson Detroit Police
Department I'm here to see mr. Elijah
Kamsky please come in I would have loved
to see more on the aspect of having an
Android how other people perceive if you
have an Android I mean it's kind of
weird right
you buy like this beautiful looking girl
just serve us hours of your home that's
kind of twisted in of itself right I'm
just kind of curious how other people
would perceive if you oldest sudden you
just got an Android like since there
you're right if let's say someone I
don't know just an exam pretty someone
really actually it's really there you go
nice place someone really ugly right
someone will never get someone's really
pretty gets an Android and it's kind of
like well that's kind of weird right cuz
androids haven't been a bad thing for
everybody because that's how we usually
perceive things these relationships you
can't be with someone that does it feel
we uh get on it's kind of the same how
like a lot of Japanese people want
virtual girlfriends or whatever it's not
the same obviously but it's clearly
something pathetic about that too a lot
of people that's like
it doesn't raise any existential
questions if that's what you mean
if you had an Android as a friend will
you be consider a loser to other people
I wish I could it seems like everyone
just hates them and that's to come and
you guys told my any day and investigate
things whenever
there's nothing really going on but I
don't really hear where we check that I
want to make sure I don't miss anything
doesn't make a difference if I sit or
not
glad you will see you now
oh my god she looks so creepy oh my god
there's many of them she says please
read cool that is pretty cool actually
dude this guy's electricity bill must be
off the roof
see coming up or what the Connor looks
awkward
are they need Kym
I wonder what they're talking about
dude he looks creepy
I'm lieutenant Anderson this is Connor
what can I do for you lieutenant sir
we're investigating deviance I know you
left several life years ago but I was
hoping you'd be able to tell us
something we don't know
oh so yeah this is the creator forgot I
just didn't recognize deviance
fascinating aren't they perfect beings
with infant intelligence now they have
free will
machines are so superior to us
confrontation was inevitable humanity's
greatest achievement threatens to be its
downfall isn't ironic
yeah
we need to understand how androids
become deviance do you know anything
that could help us all ideas of viruses
spread like epidemics is the desire to
be free a contagious disease listen I
didn't come here to talk philosophy the
machines you created may be planning a
revolution either you can tell us
something that'll be helpful or we will
be on our way and yeah they're really
violent too
what about you Connor whose side are you
on
I have no side I was designed to stop
deviance and that's what I intend to do
well that's what you're programmed to
say but you
what do you really want
I feel like we're still somewhat neutral
I don't want anything I am a machine oh
okay hey Chloe I'm sure you're familiar
with the Turing test your formality
simple question of algorithms and
computing capacity what interests me
it's whether machines are capable of
empathy I call it the Kamsky test it's
very simple you see
magnificent isn't it well the first
intelligent models develop a cyber life
young
and beautiful forever
flower that will never with her
what does it really I'm sure she needs
to continue or a living being
with a soul
just a little test it's up to you to
answer that fascinating question does
why is Hank not interfering release or
spirit if you feel it's alive but you'll
leave here without having learned
anything from me oh this is a tricky one
okay I think we're done here come on
kind of let's go sorry to get your
important to you Connor
your investigation or the life of this
Android okay now he spelled it out more
clearly we're gonna spread the Android
and obedient machine
[Music]
why living B
endowed with freewill
that's enough Connor will leave and pull
the trigger
Connor don't and I'll tell you I guess
everyone probably once Connor to be
human right alright make sure I'm
pressing the right button here so our
life's last chance to save humanity is
itself oh I'm not a deviant you prefer
to spare a machine rather than
accomplish your mission you saw
living being in this Android you should
the war is coming
you'll have to choose your side will
they betray your own people or stand up
against your creators welcome be worse
than nothing to choose between two evils
let's get out of here Thank You Hank
finally by the way I always leave an
emergency exit to my programs you never
know where does he mean by that
why didn't you shoot
I just saw that girl's eyes and I
couldn't that's all you were saying you
would do anything to accomplish your
mission yeah a chance to learn something
and you let it go yeah I know what I
should have done I told you I couldn't
I'm sorry okay getting defensive that
kind of boy huh oh maybe you do the
right thing Hank
likes me yay this is all that matters in
this playthrough this is the only goal
of anything at this point dad actually
you know necessarily I think my door is
ringing I don't know I can't be bothered
sorry mailman you know how many packages
I get once the company has your address
they'll just keep sending new stuff so
do I
I could literally start at the you two
doesn't work out I can literally start a
cardboard factory or something I
recycled so much I swear to God I spent
like an hour a day just recycling
packages cuz it might say I get so many
as well I think I'm going crazy with
these cardboards man it's like stop
please stop and then sometimes you get a
note cuz you're not in and then be like
all you have to go and collect it and
there you go and collect it and it's
like oh it's a pin from this company
that's great thank you I'm glad I am
glad I took time out of my day to
collect this hat
I just wanted to say to think my
cardboard I come here often it's like
being along with the world
well why do you disturb me people and
they're still coming from all over the
city
those who dream of freedom come to
Jericho something's changing
it's not good enough you seem
preoccupied
they all obey me they follow me without
question yeah this is what I was saying
and that much power feels good and scary
at the same time this is how I feel
about nine year old they're afraid of a
civil war many of our people were burned
in response to what happened
the humans hate us they'll never give us
our freedom no I disagree they won't
listen well fight you haven't said much
about yourself since you've been with us
what was your life like before Jericho I
wrote this song it's cool all right
I was caring for an old man it was like
a father of me
he showed me that humans and androids
can live together
what about you you never told me about
your past what did you do the women love
this you asked about them immediately
and we all have something we want to
forget don't over generalize Felix I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm you are oh just give
them give us some trust they like nice
we're fighting together we say no hit
over the trust the finish each other was
nothing
darling a distributor program to set us
by humans just a toy designed for their
pleasure
one day I was with a man who rented me
what do you do realized I couldn't take
it anymore I strangled him and I ran
away oh my god you're a murderer under
there
Wow I don't know you I want to hear his
side of this story connect this is how I
enjoyed make love like avatar
okay excuse me
demonetised thank you I was nasty
I saw your memories Oh lover why they
left you for dead in a studio
I saw your memories soon
the Eden club to death of that man I
felt like I was there with you
north
mm-hmm
you just got to hit him with compassion
empathy and Trust BAM you got yourself a
wife like how did that happen zero for
Mandarin they so over I know I over
generalize a lot while playing this but
that's cuz the game does it every
stereotype ever it has hey he's back
he's back
hooray yes and realizes he's back
Hey
that's sweet
this is suicide I'm gonna play for it
night together what is this you don't
understand we're finally gonna show that
we really are this place will go down in
history that's the risk I'm prepared to
take it means freedom for our people
Marcus please don't do this they'll
understand we'll make them understand
this is the only way
what is that for tonight skin from there
are androids here who could join us the
more we are the stronger our message I
mean yeah if you just have to touch
people to convert them then you're free
hey you're free convert more Androids
I don't really see any go to the stream
you stared at my Android hey hey come
with us we're doing some shopping she
was picking up pain as well
you're awake now we're gonna have a
pizza party it's gonna be epic
block the road you're free now hey it's
that guy hey wait
I don't think so I don't think some big
chump well he was easily easily
convinced
I need to block the street
do you speak English I need a street
blockage am I not doing the same thing
as the humans in a way
forcing people androids to do my work
for them I mean the opposite well
English isn't that really open manhole
ten why not woman hole why not her hole
makes me angry
there you go guys hope you had fun down
there let's convert some more oh it's
Cara free no wait I can do it from a
distance now she's abandoned the baby
this is their band and a baby in the
snow bazinga
come on join me guys I'm basically Jesus
what is hey you you're the man yeah
that's right
13 are you now you domain now you demand
that's right now you domain you demand
y'all the man why the man huh you don't
wear man you do wear man why one man why
not whoa Wow huh tip we live in a man's
world
[Music]
you demand you domain you're the well
cool epic hacker no problem
why did she have any problem with me
doing this she was like no we shouldn't
do this
this is super chill your I'm the WA you
do I wa Judah Wawa
Yuda wah-wah
Alexa
this is Wow Wow
[Music]
what are you gonna do arrow must tell
all humans advance you can't kill all of
us
you better not shoot me hey hey hey
don't [ __ ] him swear especially about
Jesus
Cheryl singing hydrates no more slavery
we are a left
we are gamers we are gamers
you know in today's society nothing like
this would ever come to this point
anyway people would already be
empathetic
I mean pts right people are empathetic
about people's toasters like I don't
really see any exactly look how many
guns we have guys so you better be
careful there we came here to
demonstrate peacefully and tell humans
that we are living beings all we want is
to live free we've done no harm then
disperse chief says until we have
secured our freedom I mean technically
it isn't illegal
yeah okay that's a bit hard
if we attack we'll start a war we have
to show them we're not violence we
should just stand their ground even if
it means dying here dying here won't
solve anything
Marcus we need to go now
before it's too late I think we should
go you can demonstrate legally you just
have to sign up for it first I we should
shoot
oh [ __ ] this is messed up dude Oh
Jericho did not like that northen I miss
aah oh my god everyone aids me Oh Simon
okay Simon my man
Simon's alright this is the kind of
decision I know everyone's gonna hate me
more I didn't know that we're gonna
shoot me
I wanted the peaceful revolution to work
please don't be angry okay look we got
the ultimate options because it's on top
so that means this is the best outcome
cuz it's it's much higher than the other
ones and further ahead as well as so I
think this is dead we should be happy
about this decision definitely well if
you like if you enjoyed watching I will
be back tomorrow with another episode
thank you guys so much and goodbye